dans l'atelier de Charlie lesquels on va
en voir de toutes les couleurs
dans un registre surprenant celui du
langage des mains en croire son guide en
la matière la peinture constituée un
formidable potentiel pour se découvrir
et bien plus encore
mes voyages c'est là où moi le mieux
parce que
nous menti la montagne
vraiment l'expression c'est de dire
Malika paramy fait pas top personnes par
contre il fait moins du bien aujourd'hui
on parle beaucoup de de médecine douce
et on passe beaucoup par des médiations
artistiques que ce soit la peinture que
ce soit le chant que ce soit la danse le
tout en fait c'est de d'arriver à un
certain lâcher prise et de laisser aller
de de mettre stop en fait sur le mental
pour que justement on arrête d'être dans
dans le jugement dans l'auto sabotage et
tout ça il faut nous regarder
camion
sortir de son cadre de prédilection de
sa zone de confort un challenge ou
plutôt une passerelle car les peintres
et chanteurs ont décidé de sensibiliser
le public à l'hypertension diabète
insuffisance rénale obésité sur la place
de la capitainerie juste en face du de
l'atelier de Charlie Lescun il y aura
une action de prévention et de dépistage
autour des complications de ces maladies
chroniques et en même temps on va couper
les choses justement c'est l'espèce de
maillage entre la culture et la santé où
il y aura des artistes qui viendront
faire des performances artistiques
souvent les artistes moins dans les
vanissages là nos couples le le ce
soir-là ne les donne chemin nous est une
place publique maman il ne les
accessible via fait des pissazotes via
avoir un autre travail
des artistes qui poursuivront leur
parcours en Chine où ils participeront
un festival Art science un échange
destiné d'une part à faire découvrir la
culture réunionnaise et d'autre part à
détecté des référents en diététiques
chinoise et en médecine traditionnelle a
accueillir à la Réunion
le roi de les